y
[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 sus casos se han
convertido en un grito de guerra para
activistas y grupos de derechos humanos
cubanos tras un año de detención los
artistas visitantes luís manuel otero
alcántara y maggiolo sorbo fueron
condenados el 24 de junio a 5 y 9 años
de prisión respectivamente por delitos
como difamación de las instituciones y
organizaciones cubanas y ofender la la
bandera nacional entre otros muchas
organizaciones criticaron este juicio
realizado a puertas cerradas los dos
hombres participaron en varias protestas
antigubernamentales y aparecen en el
famoso videoclip de patria y vida el
himno oficial del movimiento y del lado
de turquía otros músicos están luchando
para seguir subiéndose al escenario
conciertos cancelados festivales
prohibidos la presión se acentuó estos
últimos meses contra algunos artistas
como esta cantante emelec mosso cuyo
próximo concierto fue canción por
considerar que promovía ella la
inmoralidad varios otros artistas están
acusados de comportamiento inadecuado o
de cantar en un idioma regional es que
los conservadores intentan a recuperar
el control musical del país pero estas
prohibiciones contribuyen a empañar la
imagen del presidente arduán entre los
jóvenes
seguimos nuestro tour de la actualidad
cultural internacional con una buena
noticia que viene de ucrania el 25 de
junio se repitió
1984 la icónica obra de george orwell en
un teatro de la capital kiev por primera
vez desde el inicio de la invasión rusa
la representación del clásico distópico
cobró una nueva relevancia en el país
atravesado por la invasión rusa esta
primera función en cuatro meses de
guerra fue recibida con alegría hasta
que la representación fue interrumpida
por las sirenas que alertan sobre ataque
es un ejemplo de que la reanudación
normal de la vida cultural en nieve está
lejos de ser ganada pero también de que
tanto los habitantes como los artistas
están redoblando sus esfuerzos para
mantenerla viva
en esta edición les queríamos también
llevar a conocer al artista visual
chileno iván navarro y sus instalaciones
de luz y espejos que exploran la
dimensión estética y política de la
electricidad nació y creció en santiago
vive en nueva york pero 2022 es un año
de mucha actividad para él en territorio
europeo nuestra corresponsal nadie haría
ver ruiz encontró le encontró durante su
paso por basilea en suiza y nos cuenta
más sobre sus últimos trabajos y sus
reflexiones sobre estos dos años de
pandemia
el concepto de espacio es central en la
obra de iván navarro en basilea el
chileno presentó su más reciente
creación lejos de sus conocidas
instalaciones de luz se trata de un
libro titulado landmark su protagonista
manhattan tras los ataques contra uno de
sus emblemas el 11 de septiembre las
torres gemelas eran un langar las
personas sienten que hay partes del
cuerpo humano por ahí escondidas que
cayeron a las calles y fueron de alguna
forma
resignificando la ciudad para
materializar esa sensación que navarro
asimila a las desapariciones durante la
dictadura chilena en la que creció tomó
un mapa de la zona y rebautizó las
calles con partes del cuerpo humano al
pasar las páginas el mapa se desvanece
el mensaje es universal
hay un factor
completamente visual tú no tienes que ni
siquiera saber leer para poder ver este
libro y ver que algo está pasando con la
idea de desaparición o que la ciudad
empieza a desaparecer que los nombres de
las calles comienzan a desaparecer
además de la ciudad de encarnada y
bandas barro se interesa en la
representación que el hombre hace del
cielo tema de su actual exposición en la
galería templo de bruselas tratamos de
representar el espacio y en este caso la
metáfora del universo de una forma como
tratando de controlar la visión que
tenemos del espacio entonces siempre
tratando
de darle un sentido a lo que se ve o lo
que no se puede controlar
entonces la idea es que las personas se
sientan envuelta en esta en el espacio y
tiene esa inspiración de esta foto como
espectaculares que de repente se ven
desde las nebulosas aquí trabaja por
primera vez con pintura una idea que
nació durante el confinamiento ahí
comencé a volver al trabajo más manual
con herramientas e incluso yo mismo
haciendo haciendo todo entonces fue un
momento que yo le llamo como un momento
más espiritual asegura que es muy pronto
para pensar en su legado pero la obra en
la que trabaja desde hace cinco años
dejará una marca indeleble pues fue
invitado a crear una de las nuevas
estaciones que tendrá el metro de país
volvemos al mundo musical y cerramos el
programa de esta semana con el estreno
de dos temas colaborativos que no se
esperaban en el remix de su canción
danzarín ya el dj productor brasileño
pedro sampaio logra reunir a las
estrellas nacionales en sí pedrinho y
anita con el reguetonero puertorriqueño
nicky jam y el franco congoleño tachó un
mensaje de fiesta y diversión en tres
idiomas y un videoclip que le hace honor
al pasillo un estilo de baile que nació
en las favelas y que siempre acompaña a
los ritmos tan característicos del funk
brasileño
y nos despedimos con el tema sorpresa de
los legendarios de rap en indian y snoop
dogg prontitud elvis y su primera
colaboración en dos décadas gracias a
ustedes por su confianza y cuídense
[Música]
[Aplausos]